in this video we take a look at the data
processing necessary to train causal
language models
causal language modeling is the task of
predicting the next token based on the
previous ones
another term for causal language
modeling is autoregressive modeling
in the example that you can see here the
next token could for example be nlp or
it could be machine learning
a popular example of course of language
models is the gpt family of models
to train models such as gpt we usually
start with a large corpus of text files
these files can be web pages scraped
from the internet such as the commgrol
dataset or they can be python files from
github like the ones you can see here
as a first step we need to tokenize
these files such that we can feed them
through the model
here we show the tokenized text as bars
of various length illustrating that
there are shorter and longer ones
this is very common when working with
text
however transform models have a limited
context window and depending on the data
source it is possible that the tokenized
texts are much longer than this window
in this case we could just truncate the
sequences to the context length
but this would mean that we lose
everything after the first context
window
using the return overflowing token flag
we can use the tokenizer to create
chunks with each one being the size of
the context length
sometimes it can still happen that the
last chunk is too short if there aren't
enough tokens to fill it
in this case we can just remove it
while the with the return length keyword
we also get the length of each chunk
from the tokenizer
this function shows all the steps
necessary to prepare the data set
first we tokenize the data set with the
flags i just mentioned
then we go through each chunk and if its
length matches the context length we add
it to the inputs we return
we can apply this function to the whole
data set
in addition we make sure that to use
batches and remove the existing columns
we need to remove the existing columns
because we can create multiple samples
per text and the shapes in the data sets
would not match anymore in that case
if the context length is of similar
lengths as the files this approach
doesn't work so well anymore
in this
example both sample 1 and 2 are shorter
than the context size and would be
discarded with the previous approach
in this case it is better to first
tokenize each sample without truncation
and then concatenate the tokenized
samples with an end of string or eos
token in between
finally we can chunk this long sequence
with the context length and we don't
lose too many sequences because they're
too short anymore
so far we have only talked about the
inputs for cause and language modeling
but not the labels needed for supervised
training
when we do call the language modeling we
don't require any extra labels for the
input sequences as the input sequences
themselves are the labels
in this example when we feed the token
trans to the model the next token we
wanted to predict is formers
in the next step we feed trans and
formers to the model and the label we
wanted to predict is r
this pattern continues and as you can
see the input sequences
is the label sequence just shifted by
one
since the model only makes prediction
after the first token the first element
of the input sequence in this case trans
is not used as a label
similarly we don't have a label for the
last token in the sequence since there
is no token after the sequence ends
let's have a look at what we need to do
to create the labels for causal language
modeling in code
if we want to calculate a loss on a
batch we can just pass the input ids as
labels and all the shifting is handled
in the model internally
so you see there is no matching involved
in processing data for causal language
modelling and it only requires a few
simple steps